ah i don't know my line i'm completely
done oh it's so good
i know i know a-listers who get paid the
big bucks put a lot of hard work into
their roles right
wrong at least when it comes to
memorizing their scripts
in fact in this video you'll find out
that remembering lines is basically
optional just ask robert downey jr
got any bad ideas there are actors who
require
take after take to get their scenes
right and other a-listers who just
refuse to learn the script and wear an
earpiece instead
no matter the reason you're about to be
surprised at how many of your favorite
actors walk onto set
and are constantly forgetting or haven't
even taken a look at their lines
the best part a lot of those moments
have been caught on camera
you lied sorry nothing is worse when it
comes time for a big speech or big
performance and you just
blank well according to gayton matarazzo
his stranger thinks co-star caleb
mclaughlin had this happen to him quite
a bit of the time
reset
it's really funny when he does mess up
his lines sometimes he'll have to
physically regroup
and he says the wrong thing he can't
really hold caleb accountable for being
the only one to forget his lines
it happens to all of them now and again
sorry i know
it's hard jennifer lawrence swooped into
hollywood and impressed everyone with
her apparently untrained acting skills
however her hunger games co-star josh
hutcherson made sure that the world knew
behind the scenes she isn't always
perfect
apparently j-law is notorious for
messing up her lines and would always
jokingly get called out for it by josh
and woody harrelson
when she won her oscar it got even worse
according to josh whenever she forgot a
line woody shouted things like oh
better give that oscar back at her this
wasn't exclusive to the hunger games
either
check out these hilarious bloopers what
is it
i talked to eric eric why are you
getting closer to me i'm obviously not
acting
don't let kj's impeccable american
accent fool you
of course not cole sprouse gave fans the
inside scoop on how bad kj is
at actually remembering his lines his
exact words were
kj doesn't remember any of his lines
however it isn't for lack of effort
on the plus side cole did mention that
forgetting his lines offered up
a lot more opportunities for improv and
these hilarious bloopers
epic epic robert pattinson didn't have
the greatest experience with twilight
however we're thinking that some of his
twilight woes happened because he
couldn't memorize his lines
oh sorry i can't remember anything today
in an interview he said when we do
twilight there is always someone there
who takes care of
everything and feeds you your lines when
he left the twilight set he realized
just how bad he was at remembering his
lines
while filming bellamy our pats was
expected to memorize his script
his response impossible i realized how
rusty and slow my brain has become
the proof is in the bloopers what what
wait for what you're lying to finish oh
tom holland supposedly claims that he
isn't the one who constantly messes up
on set
but his spider-man far from home
bloopers say otherwise
before peter parker knew mysterio was
hiding something
mysterious their meat cute was kind of
adorable
however it took many takes before tom
holland was able to compose himself
remember his lines and deliver a
camera-worthy performance
cole may find kj's inability to remember
lines humorous but
maybe that's because he's forgotten
about his time on friends
he had the biggest crush on jennifer
aniston
so intimidated by my by my crush on her
that i completely blanked and forgot
every single one of my lines
but that didn't stop him from correcting
the adult actors on set when they forgot
their lines
what is it your punch oh yeah
robert downey jr likes to keep himself
on his toes like the russo brothers said
downey will never say the same line
twice while filming sherlock lines were
constantly changing so he opted for an
earpiece and hired an assistant to feed
him the lines instead of memorizing them
he brought the technique over to his
avengers films as well the writers would
even come up with alternate lines a few
days before filming so he'd be surprised
each take
he chatted about it on joe rogan's
podcast pages and pages of stuff i was
like give me an earwig
and it helped me with my accent it seems
like the mcu has a bunch of actors who
have run into some problems with line
memorizing
to be fair mark ruffalo has a pretty
good excuse
his character bruce banner is constantly
spewing scientific jargon that
maybe a handful of people understand
mark is not in that handful which made
remembering the technical words and
sentences
a huge challenge xylo
plural potent cells into a
polysaccharide
[Music]
johnny depp chooses not to remember his
lines plain
and simple actually the reasoning behind
this choice is quite complicated
johnny believes that if he memorized his
lines he wouldn't be able to portray his
character through other parts of his
body
like his eyes it had to be behind the
eyes and my feeling is that if there's
no truth behind the eyes
doesn't matter what the words are for
films he hires someone to whisper his
lines to him on set through an earpiece
so he isn't constantly wondering what
line is next
it works take a peek at his list of
blockbuster hits
you can keep barbosa the blizzard
homunculus in his
harry potter's very own dumbledore isn't
the spry fry he was in his early acting
days
he's admitted that i can't remember
lions anymore
it's even caused him to drop stage
acting and be more selective with his
movie roles
at first wearing an earpiece like johnny
depp and rdj
didn't sit right with him but he gave it
a try and now uses it for the majority
of his film roles
outer banks actress madeleine klein had
a few bumps in the road while filming
her breakout netflix series
she did a phenomenal job bringing sarah
to life
but it wasn't without ruining quite a
few takes before getting it perfect
there's one scene in particular that
revealed madeleine's struggle with
some of the show's dialogue check it out
and more as always when me
and more as always
before ashley benson became a pretty
little liar she started off on the soap
opera days of our lives
which made her realize just how
important line memorizing was
by the time she landed her role on pll
she was a pro
however before that her anxiety and
panic attacks prevented her from being
able to not only memorize lines but to
give a confident performance on set
i started getting panic attacks for two
years straight i could barely go to work
there was one moment on pll where ashley
just couldn't deliver her lines
and the same went for the rest of the
cast shay mitchell says filming the
final scene of pll was almost
impossible their emotions over the show
ending were getting in the way of them
even being able to deliver their lines
properly shay said we were all trying to
say our simple lines and couldn't even
make it through because we were bawling
the last camera shot was me crying so it
totally worked because i was already
upset
rita ora got her big acting break as mia
gray in the 50 shades of grey films
however
it wasn't exactly a dream come true she
was so nervous
and concentrated on not messing up her
american accent but she was constantly
forgetting her lines
she didn't have a huge amount of screen
time but for the scenes she was in she
had to wear an earpiece to get them
right
i had to have someone in my ear telling
me what to say before i said it i was so
nervous i forgot everything that i had
learned
i have no idea where i'm standing you're
right here so good to see you
tom cruise could not for the life of him
remember his lines for the film days of
thunder
it got so bad that it almost cost him
his life in order to be able to get the
scene right he would paste the script
pages to the dashboard of his
race car while driving extremely fast
one day it caused him to get into a
wreck that stopped production for two
days
he ended up just opting for the earpiece
to get the job done
so does this mean that actors delivering
emotional and long monologues aren't as
impressive as the world thinks they are
maybe no one could have ever guessed
that johnny depp
never remembers any of his lines we are
still mind blown
do you know of any other actors who have
a love-hate relationship with their
lines